-Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," you guys!
I'm so excited about this.
Taylor Swift
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah.
It's incredible.
While you were just applauding,
Taylor wrote three more albums.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She is unbelievable.
Loving "Midnights."
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, President Biden says
that he plans to run
for re-election in 2024.
Meanwhile,
at a rally this weekend,
President Trump
also hinted at running.
It's big news, but all I can
think about is Taylor Swift
being on the show tonight, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So you know what that means.
It's time for
"The News: Taylor's Version."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-So, Biden and Trump are both
running for re-election,
and they've got major
"bad blood,"
which everyone knows
"all too well."
Of course, Trump has quite
the "reputation."
Every other day, he's like,
"I did something bad,"
and Biden has to be like,
"This is why we can't have
nice things,"
which is why this could be
the most dramatic election
ever -- more --
Importantly --
"Evermore" importantly,
they both need running mates.
Biden is looking at Kamala like,
"You belong with me,"
while Trump is looking
at Mike Pence like,
"We are never ever
getting back together."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Like, ever.
Pence is actually considering
a run of his own,
but everyone is like,
"I forgot that you existed."
[ Laughter ]
"Long story short,"
everyone is tired of politics.
But, hey,
"you need to calm down,"
"shake it off,"
and get "ready for it,"
because "'tis the damn season."
So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go get your voting "card again,"
head to the polls --
Yeah, that was a stretch,
that one.
Head to the polls and fill in
every "blank space."
It doesn't matter
if you're blue or "red"
or even a "lavender haze."
You've got to let your voice
be heard,
both in 2024 and during
the midterms in "'22."
This has been
"The News: Taylor's Version."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
"Card again."
-Yeah.
-No, that was awful.
That was a stretch there.
Yeah, that's right.
Biden intends to run again.
And in a recent interview
on MSNBC, he was asked
about his concerns over his age.
Check out the President's
response right here.
--I think it's a legitimate
thing to be concerned
about anyone's age,
including mine.
That's not how I feel.
I can't even say
the age I'm gonna be.
I can't even
get it out of my mouth.
[ Laughter ]
-I've heard of people
dancing around their age,
but I've never seen someone
actually dance
around their age, like...
[ Laughter ]
Eventually, a middle school nun
stepped in, like,
"Leave room for the Holy Ghost.
Leave -- Leave room
for the Holy Ghost."
Secret Service
didn't know what to do.
They were like, "Should we step
in or give them alone time?
What's the call here?"
[ Laughter ]
Some more political news --
over the weekend,
former president Trump
held a rally in Texas,
and I noticed that he had
some trouble
with the word "smuggler."
Watch this.
-They deliberately surrendered
our border to vicious coyotes
and drug smaller --
I mean, these drug smug--
the smuggler.
A smuggler!
[ Laughter ]
-"These drug snugglers --
drug smuckers --
drug snickerdoodles, they --"
[ Laughter ]
He sounds like he took
whatever illegal drug
is being "smullered"
across the border.
Sounds like a guy trying
to do his first Wordle.
It's like, "Small?
Smug?
Is smulg a word?
I'm gonna try 'smulg' anyway.
Why not?
Let's see.
Oh, I'm very smart."
Speaking of Trump,
the January 6th Committee
announced that they have
subpoenaed the former president.
Yep, Trump's already
bragging like,
"I've got the biggest subpoena.
I've been saying it for years.
Nobody's subpoena
is bigger than mine."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the committee was like,
"Here's a federal document
that you can keep."
Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
Some big news from overseas --
today, Britain announced that
Rishi Sunak is going to be
their new prime minister
after Liz Truss lasted only
six weeks in office.
Yeah, when he showed up to his
new office, people were like,
"You can unpack your things,
but I wouldn't hang up
anything on the walls."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, on Thursday,
after 45 days in office,
Liz Truss
announced her resignation
as prime minister of Britain.
Let's take a look back
on all the greatest moments
of Liz Truss.
♪♪
-Good afternoon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, some sports news --
the World Series matchup
is set with the Houston Astros
taking on
the Philadelphia Phillies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, of course --
♪♪
Of course, the fans from
Philadelphia are super pumped.
Check out this video.
-Let's go, Philly!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm feeling great!
Four more!
-Come on, Phillies!
World Series, baby!
-We got married on Friday,
and the Phillies won!
-This is the best part
of the weekend, by far!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
"By far"?
-"By far."
-Oh, my God.
-A lot of people have videos
of the moment they got married,
but very few have a video
of the moment
their marriage fell apart.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Finally, scientists in Japan
have gotten closer to finding
a cure for baldness
after they were able
to grow hair follicles in a lab.
Well, they actually grew them
just outside the lab,
then they combed them over
into the lab.
[ Laughter ]
We have a great show.